hi there I'm Seth Juarez and I'm talking
with Ron Gilad bracha and Chris and
louder researchers of Microsoft and
researchers at Microsoft and junkie John
a professor soul at National University
and a visiting scholar about privacy and
AI with big data and the cloud privacy
is really really important thanks so
much for being with us thank you thank
you okay so why is privacy and anai such
a big issue well so you can imagine as
we go forward collecting more and more
data from individuals and storing data
from companies in the cloud there could
be major concerns about how this data is
aggregated and used and shared with
others that were maybe not the original
intended recipients of this data for
example let's say a person uploads their
genomic data to some kind of storage
site in the cloud and they intended to
use it to get some kind of personal
prediction of their risk of having some
kind of a disease but if that data were
stored there and then shared
accidentally or intentionally with other
parties it could be used against them in
some future situation for example there
could be profiling based on genomic data
that could lead to employment
discrimination or lots of other kind of
nefarious uses or scenarios you can
imagine interesting so why why is it a
big problem you know it's a big
challenge because you know in AI we're
all about kind of infringing your
privacy right we take all these small
bits of information and come up with
some interesting inferences about you
and now we want to say no no we on one
hand get want to get the value that I
can give you at the same time preserve
your privacy and actually you know if
you if you go back a I you know we
figure out ways if you if I could get
access to big datasets then I can do all
this magical thing that I can give you
but in some cases it's hard to get
through this data set so they might
distribute it for example between
hospitals if you want to do some medical
diagnosis or they might be distinguished
distributed between different agencies
if you
I want to do some initial security kind
of fur of predictions and without
establishing mechanisms that can give
you privacy and Trust you actually
cannot get this data in order to run all
these magical AI tools so it's not just
about you know preserving it's not just
the sooner that the 15 was talking about
it's also about our ability to run AI
right so the fundamental idea of getting
data is might be impossible if you
cannot build these distrust so I mean
it's a difficult it's a difficult
problem as a data scientist we just have
this gold miner they were like oh let's
just work on it oh and looking here's my
interesting results let me just share
the data with other researchers but how
how do you protect people at the same
time I mean that feels like a very
difficult challenge what say you yeah so
this is why I would bring together their
expertise of these people coming from
from the field of cryptography and
married with machine learning so you
know modern cryptography is more than
just you know what we studied at school
kind of okay encrypt the file and then
rip it when I want time numbers is all I
really so so actually it's magic what
they can do now these guys and they can
actually have encryption that allow you
to operate on the data while it's being
encrypted so you don't have to decrypt
it in order to to do computation on this
data you can actually operate it on it
while it's still encrypted this is
magical I don't know but I mean it feels
like because one of the things as a data
scientist is we have this data and it's
the correlations and the statistical
distributions that are that are inherent
with the data that cause the machine
learning algorithms to work I mean I've
always said machine learning is
glorified counting how do you how do you
encrypt data and still have those
relationships exist in a way that they
cannot be mined reverse-engineer well so
one of the new techniques that were
using which is very powerful it's called
homomorphic encryption this was a
problem which was open for about 30
years in the community and so it's very
exciting that very recently in the last
five to ten years we started to come up
with but initially theoretical solutions
and now practical solutions
morphic encryption allows you to encrypt
data so that you can still operate it
operate on the ciphertext do computing
you know just the basics that you need
for machine learning addition
multiplication the circuits that you
need to compute and you could perform
those directly on the ciphertext and
they still have meaning they don't they
don't just turn into gobbledygook the
ciphertext preserve their meaning as you
operate on them and the reason for that
is is that we're encoding them in an
underlying mathematical structure and
the mathematical structure preserves the
computation so the homomorphic term is
from from mathematics and it just means
that computing can be done
interchangeably with encrypting so and I
mean and I'm maybe I'm like I said I
remember encryption is prime numbers
right Bob and Alice was that was in the
textbook you know how do you preserve
those relationships in a way that allows
machine learning to work properly
but still not divulge information I know
I asked that already but it feels like
there's going to be some distributions
that are in there that are going to be
inherent in the data that are also going
to be inherent in B's in the actual
cipher text how do we protect people so
you can think of it so imagine you want
to compute things like averages of
variants of data just the basic kind of
operations so basically the computation
itself involves just you know adding
some numbers multiplying them and so on
you can do the same thing on the
encrypted data but the only difference
being that you can see the result
because it's still encrypted but you
know that over here in the cipher text
this is the average I just can't read it
so I can I can really compute these
values but on your behalf for example I
just can't see the results the only way
for me to see the result is send it back
to you you have the key and you can
decrypt it
so I actually computed the average or
the virus or you know we're going to
show here even more complex complicated
to function we can actually compute them
we just can see the result so when I'm
compared so for example I'm let's just
go in two numbers right there's when
you're using these Prime's key
you're making everything all encrypted
you're saying that I can do math in the
encrypted space get an encrypted answer
back that's right mathematically but I
don't know what it is in its original
space am i it is exactly that that's
exactly right
oh shoot well so what is it good
so you mentioned home homomorphic
encryption what is that what does that
mean because I love terms but I remember
memorizing a lot of them in collars and
forgetting them so encryption just
basically means you're taking
information and you're encoding it in
some way which means makes it
confidential
but the homomorphic term refers to the
fact that you can interchange the order
of encryption and computation so
homomorphic in mathematics just means
that when you apply some math you can
either add and multiply things first and
then apply the map or you can you know
apply the map and then do the
computation so that's what homomorphic
means in mathematics as well and that's
what it means in this context here too
so homomorphic encryption at a high
level you can just think of it as
encryption which allows you to still
compute meaningfully on the ciphertext
so if like if your because I remember
when we had under flow problems we go in
a log space and we have a change
multiply to add and you know divide to
subtract are their mathematical
analogies to that in homomorphic space
yes so in fact what's really new and
exciting about homomorphic encryption
solutions that we've come up with is
that they're based on kind of new
mathematical primitives that had not
been really widely deployed yet or used
in in cryptography they're based on
lattice based cryptography lattices are
an underlying you know mathematical
structure and researchers have have come
up with clever ways to design encryption
using lattice based cryptography and
lattice based cryptography is also not
susceptible to known attacks by quantum
computers so it also fits into a big
kind of a revolution that we're
experiencing right now which is called
post quantum
cryptography which is the attempt to
come up with crypto systems which will
be resilient to attacks from quantum
computers once quantum computers are
built in the near future
so even these even so for example if we
do these lattice based encryptions that
are homomorphic we'll be able to protect
this data now and for the foreseeable
future unless we come up with a new
computational model that exact amount
that ago so I think to keep in mind so
in theory home Orphic encryption is
allow you to take almost any computation
that we do today and run it over
encrypted data but as you know only in
theory there is no difference between
theory and practice of course so the
challenge is is performance and and this
is kind of where we bring together you
know our knowledge in machine learning
and our knowledge in cryptography in
order to make it efficient for the tasks
that we care about I see because I've
seen things encrypted that that like I
encrypt the number one and it blows up
into some huge digit are we are we
having data size issues and we're going
into encrypted space yes we have data
size issues we have computation time
issues all sorts of issues and the
challenge is how to make it so so many
people think about homomorphic
encryption as a nice theoretical
construct right you know it like you
know it keeps some mathematicians off
the street is it something that we're
going to see useful and our goal is to
make it something practical to take
problems that people care about and
allow them to do them in a private in a
very secure way so this is what we're
doing here and this is why we bring
together you know cryptographers
mathematicians machine learning
engineering put all of them together and
try to build something that's awesome so
now I feel like we talked about it I'm
getting a sense for how it's working can
you show me an example yeah yeah let me
first show you an example of DNA
prediction so imagine you had your DNA
sequencer now it's pretty affordable
right you can go out there and get your
DNA sequence and imagine there is
someone that's put our service on the
cloud that can make some predictions on
it we have maybe you have a risk factor
or something like that sure but you
might be
little reluctant of sending your just
DNA over to sir so what do you might
find out I'm super manners see exactly
exactly so what we do here is allow you
to send your DNA encrypted into the
service and you don't send the key it
just encrypted so you send them this
random bit string they can run the
prediction on your behalf and you get
the result but they didn't see your data
and they even didn't see the predictions
that they made on your behalf lever so
let's let's see that scar computer what
what we see here this is actually a DNA
of a flower in or the DNA of a human
being okay and what we want to predict
is for a specific seed how much time
will it take it to generate a flower
from the moment we seed it in the ground
so for this specific flower the average
number is 37 days okay and I'm going to
ask you to make the prediction and again
this prediction is done on the encrypted
data so I sent the request the server is
now processing and it took at about two
seconds to generate the result that for
this specific flower takes 29 days so
for those that are at home because
you're not probably seeing the screen
they're getting it ready I there's a
there's a there's a picture like this is
reminds me of the old iris data set is
that what this is no it's actually a
more sophisticated data set because it's
really DNA we have here a 200,000 sneaks
from the DNA so we're really looking at
the DNA a large portion of the DNA and
we're sending we encrypting it sending a
request to the server it takes a server
about the second or two to make the
prediction but the server doesn't see
our D our DNA and doesn't even see the
prediction that it makes that's pretty
impressive and hopefully we'll get the
demo up in a second so you can see
what's going on so effectively you have
DNA of flowers that is all it's
encrypted machine because I'm thinking
of like the model let's just say you're
making a decision tree model the
decision tree model is made over in the
encrypted space and so what you do is
you take your data you encrypt it you
give it to the model that only knows
about encrypted data it produces an
output and that output it doesn't even
know what it is give it to you you
unlock it with your key and then exactly
you can imagine that what you can do is
you can take your DNA and
and store it in the cloud and and you
can be saved because it's encrypted and
every now and then when someone comes up
with a new model you can say okay here's
my DNA my encrypted DNA run this this
prediction on my behalf and I'll get to
see the result and nothing leaks and
this is pretty impressive and by the way
they're getting two demos I want you to
see it because there are some there are
some legal implications particularly in
the in the European Union with data
that's very very very specific for
example I was at I was at Croke Park in
Dublin Ireland and they they were taking
pictures of crowds and then they want to
do machine learning over it but
according to you lot they can upload
that to the cloud and so they had to do
some stuff here send some stuff there
and it feels like if they get encrypt
all of their data and then move it up
they can do lots of work yeah that's
absolutely what we have in mind is is
that the cloud can provide
simultaneously kind of storage of
important data and also analysis so it
can able and enable a lot of new
scenarios which are very relevant to AI
that's what we call it private AI
because it can be a way for us to access
a lot of data and do learning on that
data and doing predictions without
compromising the data it feels like
though I mean let's just say we have
tons of these machine learning
algorithms out there do we all have to
agree on the same kind of encryption and
then are all the models going to have to
be relearned on this in this new
encrypted space is there going to be a
consent issue I'm saying so I think
first of all there is a distinction to
be made between the learning phase and
the inference phase what we demonstrate
here is more on the inference personal
phase when you already have the model
and we don't care how you're generated
it you can generate it on their
encrypted data you can generate it on
the unencrypted data what we have to
agree on these two things is one of the
schema how we represent the data even on
the clear and then on on the encryption
scheme itself and this is actually why
we we actually had just last week we had
a meeting with all the leading
researchers and people from the industry
working in this field starting to work
towards standards in this field
allow these kind of applications to
become reality and that's that's amazing
because now for example specifically
let's just say we're doing AI and the
medical industry where the data is very
sensitive and there's tons of laws that
the government we can now pass around
data safely build better models safely
without having to sort of get other
people's data everywhere
exactly all right so it looks like we
got our demo back listen let's take a
look at what's going on here ok so so
again what we see here we have here the
flower ok and we just click and other
server to make to to run the model for
us it takes it about one or two seconds
and we get and it sends us back the
encrypted results we decrypt it and we
see the number okay so let me let me see
if I'm understanding its right if there
is a model in the cloud yeah that has
been trained on encrypted data in this
case the model has been trained somehow
we don't care whether we don't have
trained over encrypted data or or not
ign's oh I see which makes it even even
better because now we take this flower
that's 29.1 that you're seeing there on
your screen and what we're doing is
we're encrypting locally sending this
encrypted data up and then when you push
the button it comes back and says this
is the this is how long it took the
server to do it this is what the result
is for you but it but what the server
sending back to you is this gobbledygook
exactly the computation was just the
flowering time in this particular flower
the flowering time was 29.1 days that
was the answer and that's the answer
that you decrypt one student make a nice
computation that you can imagine if it
was your DNA maybe the prediction would
have been something like our your trick
is a certain disease or something like
that you don't want it server to know
that I don't want any think that you
want to know what yeah you know what you
don't want anyone else do you to have
access to this information
what are some other potential
applications for for private AI so we
have another demo that you can see up on
the screen now this is a kind of simple
example of image processing so you can
imagine image processing is a huge
target for AI in terms of tasks and
services we'd like to be able to provide
and in this case what we're showing is
handwritten digit recognition so there's
a well-known database of feminists of
handwritten digits and in fact we've
done this demo sometimes live where you
can actually write the digit yourself
cool and then what we do is we encrypt
all of the images and send them up to
the cloud so they're in encrypted form
and the the neural net prediction
happens on the encrypted data in the
cloud so the task here is just
predicting what number is this and it's
a handwritten number and so what you see
in this demo is is that we've actually
batched together many different images
and done a prediction it took the
prediction itself in this case took
about 80 seconds but it handled about
4,000 images in that time Wow so as we
click through next these are different
images different numbers which have been
predicted and you can see in the yellow
what our prediction is the red is the
initial image and the prediction the
size of the number in the in yellow is
our confidence in the prediction so most
of these you'll see they'll have pretty
high confidence but there's a few where
there's a little bit less confidence as
to what is the correct prediction so you
send a batch of these up to the server
and it batch sent back that's why it was
82nd that's right that's pretty cool I
mean and when I'm looking at this
obviously we're looking at the Emnes
data but you could imagine sensitive
pictures for example I had a friend and
this is terrible but he was a police
officer that was trying to detect child
pornography imagine the poor officers
that have to go and sort through that
that would be terrible this kind of
technology would make it so that they
won't ever have to look at that no one
has a look at that kind of stuff which
is amazing what's next for private AI so
[Music]
they mean to Islam well again please
okay it's a creative course so Korean
government had very strong privacy laws
so banks has challenges to generate
credit score's equity credit scores from
personal data so we are working on
making
joining a private motion learning
algorithm which it takes encrypt your
training set at the input and the output
you can see model this model can be
applied to encrypt the private beta to
get credit scores it's all done without
ever seeing the private data oh yeah
and just part of the dermology is
another more than oh yeah it's an
interesting one so whole thinking
crystal heads
application kyandre the most versatile
awnings you can protect protect multi
set that is we can use we can use multi
encryption to protect and authenticate
control data is I will teach code system
such as drones smart card and Robert
this is cool so now your ape for example
you could set a drone bad information
yep but if it's not encrypted doesn't
have a key it could never know what
you're telling you to do
yep yeah we can protect this one so you
can be used for protecting humans like
okay is dangerous AI such as Skynet in
Terminator alright many people are
worrying about this yeah I love this
there's there's certainly a privacy
aspect of private AI but then there's
this safety aspect around private AI
that allows you to actually control
things from people who actually can and
should control it well we kind of run at
a time this is really interesting thanks
so much for being both bring up both the
problem and some potential solutions to
the issues surrounding privacy in data
driven world your stories have brought a
sort of others topic to life thanks so
much
Thank You Kristen Ron jung-hee for that
fascinating discussion about your work
you
[Music]